there have been 16 surprising and or
fascinating moments from Sam Altman's
World Tour I could have done a video on
each of them after watching over 10
hours of interviews I decided you know
what let's just show you everything in
one video from ai's designing new AIS to
Fresh Chachi PT leaks shooting railguns
to open source here's all 16 things I
learned in no particular order let's
start with Sam Altman's warning about
ai's designing their own architecture we
get to make the decisions about how they
work I think it'd be a mistake to just
say all right human out of the loop hand
this over do whatever you want change
your own architecture go do all these
things I think it's very important that
the future of humanity is determined by
humanity and that is like an active
choice we can make seems like a good
idea but satsukova could see one of
their models designing the next model we
are definitely very concerned about
super intelligence it will be possible
to build a computer a computer cluster
GPU farm that is just smarter than any
person that can do science and
engineering much much faster than even a
large team of really experienced
scientists and engineers
and that is crazy that is going to be
unbelievably extremely impactful it
could engineer the next
version of the system
AI building AI that's just crazy let's
return to Abu Dhabi where Sam Altman
said he enjoys the power that being CEO
of openai brings but also mentioned
strange decisions he might have to make
I mean I have like lots of selfish
reasons for doing this and as you said I
get like all of the Power of running
open AI but I can't think of like
anything more fulfilling to work on I
don't think it's like particularly
altruistic because it would be if I like
didn't already have a bunch of money
yeah the money is going to like pile up
faster than I can spend it anyway I like
being non-conflicted on openai because I
think the chance that we have to make a
very strange decision someday
um
is non-trivial speaking of big decisions
samuelman hinted twice once in Jordan
and once in India of possible regrets he
might have had over firing the starting
gun in the AI race we're definitely
going to have some huge regrets uh 20
years from now I hope all we can say is
that we did far far far more good than
bad
and I think we will I think that's true
but the downside here is is pretty big
and I think we feel that weight every
day honestly I think if
we're gonna regret something it may be
that we already pushed the button like
we've already launched this revolution
it's somewhat out of our hands I think
it's going to be great but like this is
going to happen now right like this
we've we're out of the the world is like
out of the gates I I guess the thing
that I lose the most sleepover is that
we already have done something really
bad I don't think we have but the
hypothetical that we
by launching Chachi PT into the world
shot the industry out of a railgun and
we now don't get to have much impact
anymore and there's gonna be an
acceleration towards making these
systems which again I think will be used
for tremendous good and and I think
we're going to address all the problems
but maybe there's something in there
that was really hard and complicated in
a way we didn't understand and you know
we've now already kicked this off but
back to Tel Aviv where both samuelman
and openai's chief scientist Ilya
satskova agreed that the risks from
Super intelligence were not science
fiction so the last question the super
intelligent AI That's out of control
yeah that'd be pretty bad
yeah so it's like
it would be
it would be a big mistake to build the
super intelligence AI that we don't know
how to control I think the world should
treat that not as a you know haha never
going to come sci-fi risk but something
that we may have to confront in the next
decade which is not very long on a
lighter note Sam Altman didn't seem that
perturbed not just about a deep fake of
himself but also on society getting used
to misinformation I want to play a clip
uh maybe you guys can put on a clip of
something I recently heard Sam speak
somewhere and we can talk about it a bit
could you uh play the clip please hi my
name is Sam and I'm happy to be here
today
thank you all for joining
I also wanted to say that the gentleman
on stage with me is incredibly good
looking
and I also want to say that you should
be very careful with videos generated
with artificial intelligence technology
okay so you didn't say that recently but
nonetheless I think it raises a real
question right when you know this video
if you look closely you can see the lips
aren't perfectly synced but like you
said this stuff is only going to get
better and exponentially better yeah so
that was like deeply in The Uncanny
Valley it's very strange to watch but
we're not that far away from something
that looks perfect there's a lot of fear
right now about the impact this is going
to have on elections and on our society
and how we ever trust media that we see
I have some fear there but I think when
it comes to like a video like that I
think as a society we're gonna rise to
the occasion we're going to learn very
quickly that we don't trust videos
unless we trust the the sort of
provenance if people are saying
something really important they'll
cryptographically sign it indeed
throughout the world tour salmon
repeatedly stated that he didn't believe
there should be any regulation of
current models everybody wants great
education productivity gains
discovery of new science all of the
stuff that's going to happen and no one
wants to destroy the world no one wants
to do things not even that bad but still
bad I totally believe it is possible to
not stifle Innovation and to address the
big risks I think it would be a mistake
to go regulate the current models of
today and in Poland his co-founder wajac
zaremba agreed saying the risks of super
intelligence were 10 years away also I
would say that the fear is that fear of
AI of the future not the AI of today if
the trajectory that we are on will
continue then in the decade or so
there will be build systems which are as
powerful as today corporations but if I
could speak to Sam Oldman I would bring
his attention to this paper published
this week this is a study out of Harvard
and MIT and it involved some
non-scientist students working for one
hour in that hour they were able to get
chat Bots to suggest four potential
pandemic pathogens explain how they can
be generated from synthetic DNA using
reverse genetics supplied the names of
DNA synthesis companies unlikely to
screen orders and identify detailed
protocols and how to troubleshoot them
and they say that collectively these
results suggest that llms will make
pandemic class agents widely accessible
even to people they say with little or
no lab training and then there's this
these results strongly suggest that the
existing evaluation and training process
for large language models is inadequate
to prevent them from providing malicious
actors with accessible expertise
relevant to inflicting Mass death and
that more immediately if unmitigated llm
chatbots render pandemic class agents
more accessible even to people without
training in the Life Sciences the number
of individuals capable of killing tens
of millions of people will dramatically
increase they recommend that at a
minimum new llms larger than gpt3 should
undergo evaluation by Third parties
skilled in assessing catastrophic
biological risks before controlled
access is given to the general public
notice they said larger than gpt3 so
that strongly contradicts Sam wantman's
assertion that current models like gpt4
shouldn't have any regulation they say
that even open source communities should
welcome safeguards because a single
instance of misuse and mass death would
trigger a backlash including the
imposition of extremely harsh
regulations one specific recommendation
was that if biotech and information
security expert were able to identify
the set of Publications most relevant to
causing Mass death and companies like
open Ai and Google curated their
training data sets to remove those
Publications then future models trained
on the curated data would be far less
capable of providing anyone intent on
harm with the recipes for the creation
or enhancement of pathogens this seems
like an absolutely obvious move to me
and I think Ilya satskova would agree we
are talking about as time goes by and
the capability keeps increasing you know
and eventually it goes all the way to
here right right now we are here today
that's where we are that's what we're
going to get to
when you get to this point then yeah
it's very powerful technology
it can be used for amazing applications
you can say cure all disease
on the flip side you can say create a
disease
much more worse than anything that
existed before that'd be bad
moving on to the chat gbt Elite it seems
like we're going to get a new workspace
where we can customize our interaction
with chattybt giving it files and a
profile with any information that you'd
like chat gbt to remember about you and
your preferences this was hinted out on
the world tour when one of Sam Altman's
guests Johannes Heidecker from openai
research talked about customizing models
we are trying to make our models both
better at following certain guardrails
that should never be overwritten not
with jailbreaks not if you ask nicely
not if you threaten it and we're also
trying to make our models better at
being customizable making them listen
more to additional instructions of what
kind of behavior the user or the
developer wants on a lighter note the
leaders of openai were asked in Seoul
the capital of South Korea about the
mixing of AI and religion do you expect
AI to replace the role of religious
organizations like church
I I think I think that it's a good
question how
all sort of human societies will
integrate Ai and we've already seen
people building AI pastors for example
and so the constituents can ask
questions of this pastor the cite Bible
verses and it can can give advice but
now back to Poland where Sam Altman
called open source Unstoppable realizing
that open source is Unstoppable and
shouldn't be stopped and so this stuff
is going to be out there and as a
society we have to adapt speaking of
stopping AI samuelman was asked about
his own loved ones and in response he
gave a utopic vision of the future and
called the current world barbaric if you
truly believe that AI imposes a danger
to humankind why keep developing it
aren't you afraid for your own dear ones
and family I think it's a super fair and
good question and the most Troublesome
part of our jobs is that we we have to
balance this like incredible promise in
this technology that I think
humans really need and we can talk about
why in a second with confronting that
these very serious risks why to build it
number one I do think that when we look
back at the standard of living and what
we tolerate for people today it will
look even worse than when we look back
at how people lived 500 or a thousand
years ago and we'll say like man can you
imagine that people lived in poverty can
you imagine people suffered from disease
can you imagine that everyone didn't
have a phenomenal education were able to
live their lives however they wanted
it's going to look barbaric I think
everyone in the future is going to have
better lives than the best people of
today I think there's like a moral duty
to figure out how to do that I also
think this is like Unstoppable like this
is the progress of Technology it won't
it won't work to stop it and so we have
to figure out how to manage the risk it
doesn't seem to be a hundred percent
sure on this front though and here is an
interview he gave with the guardian when
he was in London for his world tour
speaking of superintelligence said it's
not that it's not stoppable if
governments around the world decided to
act in concert to limit AI development
as they have in other fields such as
human cloning or bioweapon research they
may be able to but then he repeated but
that would be to give up all that is
possible I think that this will be the
most tremendous Leap Forward in quality
of life for people that we've ever had I
did try to get tickets for the London
leg of His World Tour but they were sold
out within half an hour oh well
samuelman does think that behavior will
change however when these AGI Labs stare
existential risk in the face one of the
things we talked about is what's a
structure that would let us warmly
Embrace regulation that would hurt us
the most and now that the time has come
for that we're out here advocating
around the world for regulation that
will impact us the most so of course
we'll comply with it
I think it's more easy to get good
behavior out of people when they are
staring existential risk in the face and
so I think all of the people at the
Leading Edge here these different
companies now feel this and you will see
a different Collective response than you
saw from the social media companies and
in terms of opportunities both samuelman
and Ilya satsukver talked about solving
climate change I don't want to say this
because climate change is so serious and
so hard of a problem but I think once we
have a really powerful super
intelligence addressing climate change
will not be particularly difficult for a
system like that we can even explain how
here's how soft climate change you need
a very large amount of carbon cup of
efficient carbon capture you need the
energy for the carbon capture you need
the technology to build it and you need
to build a lot of it if you can
accelerate the scientific progress which
is something that the powerful AI could
do we could get to a very Advanced
carbon capture much faster it could get
to a very cheap power much faster it
could get to cheaper manufacturing much
faster now combine those three cheap
power cheap manufacturing Advanced
carbon capture now you build lots of
them and now you sucked out all this all
the excess CO2 from the atmosphere you
know if you think about a system where
you can say tell me how to make a lot of
clean energy cheaply tell me how to
efficiently capture carbon and then tell
me how to build a factory to do this at
planetary scale if you can do that you
can do a lot of other things too yeah
with one addition that not only you ask
you to tell it you ask it to do it
that would indeed be amazing but think
of the power we would be giving to an AI
if it was able to just do it just create
those carbon capture factories if we did
make that decision one thing that would
help would be reducing hallucinations I
think we will get the hallucination
problem to a much much better place it
will take us my colleagues William I I
think it'll take us a year and a half
two years something like that but at
that point we won't still talk about
these Sam Altman talked about that in
New Delhi that time frame of 18 months
to two years is ambitious and surprising
but now on to jobs which Samuel was
asked about on every leg of the tour on
this front though I do think it was Ilya
satsukovar who gave the more honest
answer economic dislocation indeed like
we already know that there are jobs that
are being impacted or they're being
affected in other words some chunks of
the jobs can be done you know if you're
a programmer you don't write functions
anymore co-pilot writes them for you if
you're an artist though it's a bit
different because a big chunk of the
artists economic activity has been taken
by some of the image generators and
while new jobs will be created it's
going to be a long period of economic
uncertainty there is an argument to be
made that even when we have full human
level AI full AGI people will still have
economic activity to do I don't know
whether that's the case but in either
event we will need to have something
that will allow for a soft soften the
blow to allow for a smoother transition
either to the totally new profession
that will exist or even if not then we
want government the social systems will
need to keep Kane I do think the changes
in the job market will be dramatic and
will be following the story closely one
thing I definitely agree with Samuel
Manon though is the Deep almost
philosophical change that this solving
of intelligence has brought to humanity
so I
grew up implicitly thinking that
intelligence was this like really
special human thing and kind of somewhat
magical and I now think that it's sort
of a fundamental property of matter
and
that's that's definitely a change to my
world view the history of scientific
discovery is that humans are less and
less at the center you know we used to
think that like sun rotated around us
and then maybe at least we were if not
that we were like going to be the center
of the Galaxy and there wasn't this big
universe and then Multiverse like really
is kind of weird and depressing and if
intelligence isn't special like again
we're just like further and further away
from like main character energy but
that's all right that's sort of like a
nice thing to realize actually it's a
bit like a copernican and darwinian
Revolution all rolled in one I'll give
the final word to Greg Brockman in Seoul
who talked about the unpredictability of
scaling up models 10 times right that is
the biggest theme in the history of AI
is that it's full of surprises every
time you think you know something you
scale it up 10x turns out you knew
nothing um and so I think that we as a
Humanity as species are really exploring
This Together
being all in it together and knowing
nothing sounds about right but thank you
for watching to the end I know that
samuelman has a couple more stops I
think it's Jakarta and Melbourne on the
world tour and I'll be watching those of
course but for now thank you and have a
wonderful day